uh mr bryant how long have the committee
known about this email
for the last week we've had it and and
obviously we had a session of the
foreign affairs committee yesterday but
can i just remind people why this
matters um
i along with many well nearly every mp i
i know
had hundreds and hundreds of um
constituents uh relations and friends
and people who've worked with armed
forces british armed forces in
afghanistan who got stuck in afghanistan
so what we've been trying to do on the
foreign affairs committee is trying to
dig away at why did some people get left
behind um but pen farthing and nausea
were allowed to evacuate their animals
and
whether you think that that was the
right decision or the wrong decision
what we came up against was first of all
we had the prime ministers the prime
minister saying it had absolutely
nothing to do with him the prime
minister spokesperson saying it had
nothing to do with him or um
uh carrie
mrs johnson and and yet
um we had the prime minister's pps
saying that he'd been involved in the
decision which was then denied and now
we've got a letter from lord goldsmith
or from lord goldsmith office making it
absolutely clear that the prime minister
was involved so in a sense this goes
back to the moral authority of the prime
minister and whether the prime minister
tells the truth
but do we know um
the email says the prime minister
authorized this that's what the email
says but are you confident that it means
that that he did he authorized it or
could it be a certain amount of
grandstanding uh or inflammation by the
person writing the emails that goldsmith
who clearly had his own agenda wanting
to to get his charity uh in a place
where they could get people out of
afghan afghanistan
so either a government minister in the
house of lords and who's a minister in
the foreign office has lied or the prime
minister has lied
uh i'll kind of take your pick
um
you know i i merely know that the prime
minister himself earlier today said in
prime minister's questions and that the
code of the ministerial code applies to
him um and if somebody has lied um then
they do need to resign and i know
my anxiety about this is i care
passionately about um the situation in
ukraine the foreign affairs committee we
visited ukraine last week we went to
within 80 meters of russian troops
um and you know stared at them down
binoculars kind of thing
and we are aware that we need a prime
minister at this moment who has all the
moral authority he can muster
and yet there are endless stories about
whether he's told the truth whether he's
cut corners whether he's told fibs and
it just means that it's so corrosive in
british politics we've changed prime
ministers quite often in times of war uh
lloyd george quite rightly took over
from asquith in 1916 and of course most
famously chamberlain had to give in um
um in 1940 and was replaced by winston
churchill i just think
to be honest that with all these stories
crowding in on the prime minister he has
no moral authority he has no ability to
lead the country and and
you know this is just another part of a
of a massive jigsaw of
of what i've called before a shower of
shenanigans
the number 10 have released a statement
just a short time ago down down in
street says it remains the case that the
prime minister didn't instruct officials
to take any particular course of action
um what do you say to that
i just don't believe him all right so is
he sacking lord goldsmith for telling
fib i mean what has happened now is of
course that the prime minister should
come to the house of commons tomorrow
and answer questions on it pretty
straightforward um you know he his
authority and his integrity and his
honor are on the line and he should come
to the chamber and defend it
what evidence do you have that that
animals and staff from this charity were
given priority over other people
well we've already asked a whole series
of officials um in the foreign affairs
committee about about the process
whereby they were given um they were
given permission to land and it was an
additional slot that was provided which
could have been made available to other
people to people rather who could have
been evacuated instead i mean we've also
i mean my my personal feeling is whilst
of course the military did a fabulous
job and lots of people did a great job
in trying to process people very very
quickly
that one of the problems was that the
foreign secretary himself was so
um
he kept on making new promises to new
categories of people who are going to be
evacuated and by the end there was no
sense of priority whatsoever which meant
that people who were extremely
vulnerable people who'd worked alongside
british forces and and whose lives were
at risk and when the taliban took over
were left behind um so some of us
notwithstanding the fact we managed to
get a large number of people out are
very very critical of the fact that the
the process was so badly handled
especially when you consider that the
government had well 18 months and more
to prepare for this eventuality and and
had been and it had been predicted by so
many people
and
in terms of the committee and you said
you've had this email for a week what
has been the reaction of those on the
committee
uh that's i'm afraid as chair of the
standards committee um i know the rules
quite well and and it's not for me to
reveal what uh members of the standards
committee of the foreign affairs
committee think in a private
deliberation but
we will be returning to this i'm
absolutely sure